There are many ways to move a camera through a scene. We can walk or fly. We
can look one direction while moving another and so on. Here we're moving a bit
sideways and a bit forward while looking forward. I usually think of the camera
as being in one of two modes, viewer-centric or model-centric. When things are
viewer-centric the viewer is moving around through the world. When
model-centric, a particular object in a world is being studied and the viewers
goal is to see this object from different angles. In this mode we keep the
camera focused on a location as we move. The place where we look is called the
Target in 3JS. And in other systems. Note that this Target location is not at
all necessary in making the various matrices need for viewing the scene. The
target is much more related to user intent. Because the target is such a useful
concept, many, but not all, camera control systems support the idea of a target
in some way. To set the target we use the camera control's target parameter.
We've set this parameter before. It provides the point that our camera is
looking at, so setting the view matrix. By setting the target in the camera
controls, you not only set the camera's view transform, you keep the camera
pointed at this location when you orbit. If the object is moving, you can
update the target each frame, and the camera will stay trained on it.